Well, the war against Iran has begun to
spiral out of control, it would seem,
over the past few days. Of course, we
saw President Trump announcing that
talks with Iran have gone very well
after uh, of course, a massive bombing
campaign that was targeting their energy
infrastructure. But then Iran responds
and says that no, there were no talks
with Trump and they claimed that he
retreated from the talks. But meanwhile,
boots on the ground, thousands of
Marines being deployed to the region.
This seems to be spiraling out of
control. Professor Xiang on his
Substack, his predictive history
Substack wrote this. The US Iran
endgame. We are but 3 weeks into this
senseless and pointless war, and it
seems certain now that the Americans
will commit boots on the ground. The
Pentagon is deploying an additional
5,000 troops to the Middle East. And
Netanyahu has reappeared to say that the
war must be won on the ground, not from
the air. Trump has asked for $200
billion from Congress, signaling that he
intends to fight a long war. Well, we're
thrilled now to have here on the show,
Professor Xiang. He's the author of
Predictive History on Substack. Welcome
to Redacted. Great to have you here.
>> Thanks so much, Clayton. I love your
show. Well, it's our pleasure to have
you here. So, you know, those are your
words just a few days ago on your
Substack. Um, as you described it, the
senseless war and committing US boots on
the ground. It seems that that part of
the story is ramping up while we get
this this rhetoric from the Trump
administration that talks have gone
great. We're about to reopen the
Straight of Hormuse. Nothing to see
here. Don't worry about your energy
prices. Where do things stand right now
uh in your estimation?
>> Right. So Trump uh these past three
weeks have been over the place. Uh every
single day he comes up of a new uh
narrative. But the reality on the ground
is that this war is following um an
escalation ladder and it seems that by
day by day um the escalation is getting
worse and uh and worse. So there's fear
now that the Israelis will strike the
power plants of uh Iran which is
targeting now the civilian
infrastructure of Iran. Iran has um uh
stated that in public um that if their
power plants are attacked then they will
respond by targeting the energy
infrastructure of the GCC and possibly
the disselination plants as well. And so
right now the GCC especially the UAE uh
it's they're facing an extension crisis.
The UAE has doubled down and said that
they themselves want to remove the
Iranian threat once uh and for all. uh
and the Israelis are completely
committed to the fight. So, it seems
like all the different actors uh want
this to escalate.
>> Now, you've become a bit of an internet
celebrity because you have this ability
to see things at a higher level than the
rest of us. So, while the rest of us are
like, "Oh, he said this, maybe this is
happening, and what about this? What do
we think about this?" You use game
theory to understand it at a broader
context, which I have found both
comforting and terrifying at the same
time. Can you respond to how the
internet has responded to you, you know,
on a personal level, but then also how
are people actually then making choices
in their lives based on what you say?
Because I know for me it's like, okay,
we better, you know, think about what
our plans are in our family. We better
think about what is our emergency
response. And so, can you can you talk
about some of the response to you and
then also what's practical for the rest
of us that are just watching this war in
horror?
Yeah, sure. Um, so for the past two
years, I've been developing a new system
of predictive modeling where I take game
theory and I make predictions about how
world events will turn out. And by
making these predictions, I can better
refine my game theory model. And so two
years ago, I made three predictions. Um,
the first predict prediction is that
Trump would win the 2024 general
election, become the 47th president of
the United States. Second prediction is
that he would initiate a war with Iran.
And the third prediction is that the
United States would lose this war and
ultimately this would reshape the global
order. So I did this uh as a thought
experiment. Uh I'm just a high school
teacher in China. I'm trying to get my
students excited in learning. I'm trying
to increase their critical thinking
skills and I myself am curious about how
the world works. So I developed this
model and to my surprise uh it's
actually panned out and so I've received
a lot of attention online and there are
two types of attention. The first is
that there seems to be a coordinate
spirit campaign against me um mainly by
individuals who believe that I am um
maybe um attacking Israel or threatening
the Zionist project. And so there's been
quite a number of very influential uh um
media figures that have come out and
attacked me. Uh I won't name their
names, but everyone knows who they are.
And it seems coordinated because it's
the same talking points where you know
they um you know try to emulate me or
try to um
um you know um satarize me by having a a
blackboard and then writing down some
silly things and saying, "Hi, there you
go." So they're trying to satarize my
teaching style. Um and it all happened
at once. So it seems coordinated to me.
It's it's the same talking point where
they think that I make make up this
stuff on the fly. Okay. So, that is the
uh smear campaign, but there's also an
organic anger directed at me. I think a
lot of it is fear about how this world
how this war will turn out. Uh and anger
at the fact that I'm sort of using a
tragedy, a global tragedy to make a name
for myself. And I'm sympathetic towards
these people. I I mean, there are quite
a few people who I deeply admire. um
people like David Ike, you know, I've
been following David Ike for a number of
years and he's been a deep inspiration
to me, but um he himself has um
criticized me for maybe being part of
the deep state or being part of a
conspiracy in order to push an agenda.
Again, I'm just a random high school
teacher in Beijing. I think a lot of it
just comes from the confusion of how I
was able to blow up so fast um online. I
myself am also um confused by the
attention I've been getting. You know,
when I first started this YouTube
channel, it was mainly to try to build a
online community where I can exchange my
ideas with others. And my wife and I
were really optimistic about the
potential for the YouTube channel. We
were really thinking like you mean maybe
in two months time we or three years
time we would have 5,000 members and
that that would be it. 5,000 members.
Now it's over two million. Um, so it's
uh I'm just flabbergasted
um by the attention. Um, and I I and I
and I know that a lot of people who've
been working in the space for a number
of years trying to educate and enlighten
the public, people like David Ike, but
also people like Jay Dyer, um, they they
might be confused as to how this
happened. I myself am confused as well.
So So, so I'm I'm just trying to make
sense of what's happening. So to be
clear, you're not you're not part of the
deep state. You're not part of some I've
seen some people being critical saying
he's part of the Chinese Communist Party
and therefore he has an agenda. He's not
being critical of China. He's being
critical of Israel. What do you say to
that?
>> Okay, first of all, I've been very mute
about China. And the reality is that I
live and work in China. If I were to say
anything offensive about China, then my
school would get into a lot of trouble.
And uh quite frankly, they might have to
fire me. I have a family in China. I
have three young young kids. So I choose
not to say anything offensive about
China. Quite honestly, if I had nice
things to say about China, I would say
them because it would make me look good
in China. And quite honestly, um I could
make quite a lot of money for myself if
I became a fanboy of the Communist Party
in China and paredited um you know,
Communist Party talking points around
the world. So, but but I I don't want to
do that because I don't want to be a
propagandist. I I want to be an
educator. So, I've chosen to remain
silent about China. So, I think like the
criticism of me about being mute uh my
criticism of the Chinese Communist Party
is correct, but it's bec
uh the reality that is China. Okay. Um
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you for that. And
yeah, I wanted to thank you for Natalie
for bringing that up and and we wanted
to address that kind of off the top
because I know you've been getting hit
really hard with certain people on on
social media. So, thank you for that.
Can we talk about your predictive model,
though? I want to get back to this war
and what you're seeing play out here. I
mean, forget like internet
personalities, you know, critic. I want
to talk about there's thousands of
people being killed in a war that is
reshaping the global world order right
now. And if I may, I'd like to add this
because we also are parents of three.
And when I watch your content, it seems
very much not about what you want to
happen because we also have three kids.
This is not the world we want to leave
them. You've said many times, I hope
that I'm wrong. So, I don't hear in your
predictions a personal preference or a
deep satisfaction of evil or anything. I
mean, I feel kindred of the way we
report news. We hate we don't like this.
We don't want it to be this way, but if
you could tell us, give it to us
straight how you see it and we'll put
aside how we feel about what we want to
happen.
>> Yeah. So, thank you so much for that,
uh, Natalie. So, you know, when my
predictions are not correct, you know,
on on February 28th, the Americans and
Israelis attacked Tran and it's launched
the world the war that we are in now. I
couldn't sleep for two weeks. You know,
I mean, my prediction had panned out,
but I was angry. I was frustrated. I was
anxious because as you point out I have
I have three kids and I want a better
future for them. Um but as a parent I
also have a responsibility to be
truthful to them and to work hard to
build bu to build a better future. So my
hope is that um if this predictive model
is correct and people start to adopt
this predictive model then that gives us
more agency over human events and this
allows our children to build a better
world. And that's what drives me. My
love for my children, my desire to
request to them a better world that that
they have agency over. So, you know, we
have 8 billion people in this world and
most people don't know what's going on
and they choose to put their head in the
sand. And what what what I'm trying to
do, my YouTube channel, is trying to say
to people that you do matter and your
choices will affect the outcome of of
the of the world. And so, we need to
educate ourselves. we need to uh focus
on what we can do and just by doing
these two simple things we can change
the world for the better. So that that's
what mo motivates me. So as for my
predictive model um I use three um um um
mechanisms. Okay. So the first is game
theory and the idea of game theory is I
assume that you have these different
players um in the world. So United
States, Israel, Iran, Saudi Arabia, UAE
and they have different interests and
they have different strengths and they
are going to look for an optimal
strategy in order to advance their
interests. So as we know a lot of what's
happening in the Middle East is driven
by Israel's desire to achieve the
greater Israel project. um that you know
right now Israel is being dominated by
religious fanatics who believe that it
is their god-given right to control um
all the land from the Nile to the
Euphrates and that's why we're seeing
this war uh in the Middle East and
because of Israel's aggression Iran has
to respond a certain way United States
is drawn into this war and the United
States is drawn in um and the United
States has to um respond in a certain
way so that's game theory the problem
with game theory is often you're not um
allowed information or you don't have
the access information of the key
players. You don't know um how they're
thinking. You you just make assumptions.
So you need other uh mechanisms in order
to validate your theory. These two other
mechanisms are uh historical patterns
and esquetology. Okay, historical
patterns just means um can we think
about previous wars and compare contrast
how this war will war will play out
based on uh previous wars. And so what
what I've done is I've looked at the
Vietnam war. I've looked at um the
Palisian war where Athens invaded
Sicily. I've looked at uh the Nazi
Germany invasion of um Russia. And by
looking at these wars, I'm I'm able to
figure out how this war might progress.
And the third uh mechanism is
esquetology which is to say like the
people involved um whether it's Iranians
or the Israelis or the Americans these
are very religious people who believe
that um they're doing this for God. Um
they're doing this to build a better
world. And so once you understand their
esquetology once you understand their
religious worldview you can better
understand their motivations and their
strategy moving forward. So then you
have like three different strands,
right? You have game theory, estology,
and historical patterning. And if you're
able to figure out where these three
converge together, you are then able to
make accurate predictions about how
things should progress.
>> Now, you've said Iran's edge in all of
this, I believe, and if I'm misquing
you, please forgive me, is escalation
control. Like they So you're talking
about the escalation ladder. Maybe you
can lay that out because I think it's
very when people see that ladder, the
escalation war ladder, it's we've seen
it all before. We've seen it play out in
Iraq. We've seen it play out in
Afghanistan. And I saw a meme this
weekend where someone said, Clayton, you
know, the problem with three-day wars is
that they tend to last 5 years. And I
thought that just that just really hit
it. So anyway, you make the point that
Iran has been able to control the
escalation control. What exactly does
that mean in terms of the United States
and Israel's plan to actually escalate
this war?
>> Right? So the escalation ladder is just
the idea that once you start a fight, it
develops its own momentum, its own
logic. You can't really stop it. So no
two two guys go into go into an argument
thinking that they'll they'll actually
exchange punches. But what happens is
they argue, then they get emotional,
they push each other, then they uh hit
hit each other, pull a knife, then they
pull a gun. Okay. So this is the idea of
escalation ladder. Now according to this
theory uh the United States and Israel
have escalation dominance because they
can move up a far higher than Iran in
the escalation ladder because the United
States and Israel have access to uh
nuclear weapons, right? And Iran
doesn't. So in theory um the United
States and Israel have have more options
than Iran. But um if you ever been in a
fight, what you recognize is that the
weaker opponent is far is forced to be
much more strategic to to be much more
flexible, to have more control over the
situation. So I did a lot of vision
jiu-jitsu before and in Bridget
jiu-jitsu, it's all about maintaining
calm, maintaining control. And if you
are able to maintain calm control, you
can even defeat a bigger opponent who
are stronger and um uh heavier than you
are. So what we're seeing in this war is
the um Iranians are able to calibrate
the strategy far more effectively than
the Israelis and the Americans. The
Americans use something called shock and
all strategy where they go and blow
things up. All right? So the Israelis if
they want to assassinate uh the Ato um
Kai or Alajani what they do is blow up
10 blocks. Okay? It's devastating but
it's effective. It's blunt. The Iranians
on the other hand are are able to
calibrate their strikes. So like if
they're able to target target a perhaps
a military base in Bahan, they're able
to target Mossad center in uh Israel.
And so by doing that uh what is what
Iran is able to demonstrate is
confidence in its arsenal. It's able to
uh maintain diplomacy, political
diplomacy as well as global public
opinion. They're also able to divide and
conquer uh the allies. Right? So they
don't want the entire GCC teaming up
with Israel and United States. So they
just want to target um specific areas.
Um so for example, military bases, they
don't actually want to target energy
infrastructure because then that might
cause Saudi Arabia to declare war on
Iran. Um, so what we're seeing uh for
these past few weeks is whereas Israel
and the United States are choosing a
blunt instrument, shock and awe, just
blow things up, the Iranians are being
very strategic, they're being very
calculating. Another example, of course,
is a shoo where um Iran is is is able to
determine who's able to pass through the
whole moves, therefore not impacting the
global economy as much as they could.
>> [laughter]
>> Now, what's frustrating for me is that
the United States and Israel can
escalate in these horrific ways and
there's no international consequences.
So, they can destroy Gaza
on moss. They can hit a school of young
girls and there's no consequence for it.
So, as an American, it's infuriating
because there should be some
consequences so that we never do this
again.
and the world is letting us and I'm very
confused why that is. So can you explain
that variable in your game theory?
>> Right. So there is actually a major
consequence. A major consequence is the
morale of your population which affects
your will to fight. Right? So if people
believe that it is a good cause, they
are willing to commit themselves to the
fight. They're willing to make the
sacrifices necessary uh to win uh the
war. Right? So what we're seeing is look
um these soldiers these American
soldiers are not enthusiastic about this
war. Um there were these American
commanders who told their soldiers that
this um war against Iran is because um
God ordained Trump to achieve the second
coming of Jesus. And what you had was
dozens of complaints filed against these
commanders. you you're seeing um fires
break out in the in Gerald R. Ford super
carrier, right? So Gerald R. Ford
supercarrier came into uh the theater uh
hoping to have a major impact and then a
fire broke out and and then the Gerald
Ford is now forced to retreat back into
the Mediterranean. And apparently the
rumor is um the Gerald Fort is now out
of commission for the next two years
because because the damage was so um
extensive and the theory is there
there's an investigation as to whether
the the sailors deliberately set fire in
a laundry room to make to decapitate the
uh super carrier. Okay. So so you're
seeing low morale among American
soldiers. First day of the war, what
happened? all the American soldiers
changed into civilian clothes and then
fled into hotels. Uh popular opinion in
America only about 40% of the population
support this war and this is the lowest
support in the past 20 30 years. So the
consequence of not having a strategy of
not having a purpose of not having a
rationale means low morale among your
population. And this is important
because eventually if Trump wants to win
this war, he needs a ground invasion.
And already we're seeing 5,000 uh
additional troops being deployed to uh
the Persian Gulf. And a lot of people
assume they're planning an amphibious
landing somewhere, possibly Cork Island,
but also possibly a naval base uh in the
south um east of Iran. Once you commit
the ground invasion, then you're gonna
have a popular um up uprising throughout
America. You know, once you have like
this social media footage of of Marines
getting killed uh in Iran for no
particular reason, I mean, Americans
don't want to die for Epstein or Israel,
right? So, um there's a tremendous
consequence to um what what the
Americans are doing right now. Let's
talk about this air power because you've
been critical of I think you've referred
to it as the inverted pyramid where the
United States really relies on air power
more than anything whether it's drones
whether it's air you know uh with
fighter jets but Iran as Netanyahu has
said will need to have boots on the
ground in order for there to be an
effective regime change. So they see it
really across purposes. Um and then you
mentioned 5,000 Marines being there's a
really massive buildup now of UF forces
heading to that region.
It seems inevitable. I hate to say it,
but it seems inevitable,
>> right? So, um, if you want to win this
war, what you do is you spend two years
to stage 2 million troops around Iran.
Okay? So, you have you have uh 500,000
troops in Pakistan ready to assault from
southeast from the southeast uh corner.
You have um another million in Iraq uh
coming coming from the border. And then
you have another 500,000 maybe in Azaran
coming in from the north. Okay, you
about you need about two years because
you need to stockpile ammunition
um to train the soldiers to have the
order of battle ready. Okay, if you want
if you if you want to win a war, you
actually do it that way. The problem is
that America has not fought a real war
um for ever since Vietnam. 2003, the war
against Iraq was not a real war because
Saddam Hussein didn't have any air
defense. He basically gave up even
before the war began because he assumed
that Americans would not be stupid
enough to invade Iraq because that would
make Iran the regional power, right?
Because Iraq was a balance to um Iran.
Um so something miscalculated. So the
problem with the American military
machine is that it's run by the
military-industrial complex. And this is
this is something that Eisenhower warned
about in his farewell speech, right?
where he said that um there's now this
massive military bureaucracy that is
independent of uh oversight that is that
that does does not factor in the best
interest of a nation that doesn't really
care about popular opinion and all
they're interested in is creating as
many advanced weapon system as possible
in order to basically steal from
American taxpayer and then starting
these wars for don't particular reason
you know Julian Assange said it best
where u the point of the war on terror
is not to have successful wars but to
have neverending wars where the
military-industrial complex can steal as
much as it wants from the American
taxpayer. And so what we're seeing in
Iran is the failure of the milit
military industrial complex to prepare
for a modern war where your opponent is
willing to fight back asymmetrically.
Right? So we see these air defense
systems, the Patriot system, uh the fat
system, they don't really work. Even
Israel's vaunted iron dome system with
David, they don't work either. They the
the Iranians now have um are now able to
strike at will against um Tel Aviv. So
air defense doesn't really work. Then
you have these super carriers, Abraham
Lincoln, Gerald Ford. Jerro Ford cost
$13 billion. And when they came into
theater, they recognized that wow, we
could be hit by drones and missiles. So
they ran away. um they're not they're
not actually in this war. I mean they're
just flexing. And then um and then you
have these jets like the F-35. The F-35
cost $100 million each. It took it took
about 20 26 years to develop and it had
stealth technology. This is the most
advanced
um jet entire world.
>> Yeah. We were told it was unhitable.
Unhitable.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And the hit them with
like pretty limited radar. So it just
shows you the corruption of the
military-industrial complex right now in
the United States and it shows you how
the United States is not ready for this
war at all.
>> Let's take a quick break uh and then I
want to ask you more about
game theory in specific that your
prediction about the United States
eventually losing this war. So we'll be
back in just a moment. You may have seen
the conversation happening online lately
that censorship is [music] back. It's
happening everywhere. platforms are
controlling narratives and pushing the
stuff they want us to see. We need to
fight back. Well, Rumble is the only
company that has stood the test of time
and deserves our support. [music]
They've been supporting Redacted for
years and we are so grateful for that
relationship. Now, on one side, Rumble
is challenging censorship uh [music]
with platforms like us. But they also
have something that will give us
protection from big banks shutting us
off, cancelling our accounts, freezing
our cards. That's why they launched
Rumble Wallet, which is a wallet that no
one can cancel and that supporters can
use instantly to tip creators like
Redacted uh without making any middleman
enriched by taking cuts. With Rumble
Wallet, you control the money. Not a
bank, not a government, not a tech
company. And not even Rumble can touch
[music] it. It's yours and only yours.
You can buy and save digital assets like
Bitcoin and Tether Gold. And now the U
new USAT, which is a regulated stable
coin, all in one place. Tether gold is
real gold on the blockchain with
ownership of physical gold bars. [music]
USAT keeps your money steady against
inflation. No banks needed. So, show
some support for Rumble and other
creators uh with using the tip button.
You can go to wallet.rumble.com,
see all their offerings there for a more
secure banking and crypto investment
solution. Download Rumble Wallet today.
Open an account. Step away from big
banks for good. wallet.rumble.com
or search Rumblewallet in the app store.
Okay, we're back with Professor Jen.
He's the author of Predictive History on
Substack and a YouTuber with 2 million
subscribers in a short order because of
his ability to recall public events
before they happen. I guess recall is
not the the right word. So some things
that he had said in 2024 is that Trump
will win the election. He will start a
war with Iran and that the United States
would lose that war. So the war that
President Trump said would be easily won
in the days leading up to it has not
proven to be so. So Professor Jen, thank
you. Uh welcome back. I want to ask you
about this prediction. Did you think
when you predicted the war with Iran,
first of all, can you tell us why you
saw that coming when so many allies of
the Trump campaign such as Tulsi Gabbard
were against the war with Iran and why
you think the United States would lose
it? Why you knew that before the
president ever did?
>> Right. So, um, the key piece of evidence
is 20 years ago about 2002, the American
military, the Pentagon ran a war game
called the Millennium Challenge. the
Millennium Challenge. And the idea is to
look at how America could defeat Iran in
a war. And so what they did was they
asked this admiral um to fight on the
side of Iranians and asked this admiral
to figure out a strategy that could
defeat the invincible American Empire.
And so in the first iteration, what the
admiral did was he used drone swarms.
Okay, so these are cheap, you know,
drones that attack all at once and it
overwhelms the defense systems of this
of the carriers and the destroyers. And
in this iteration, the Iranians won. And
so they ran this multiple times until
finally what happened was the Pentagon
basically uh restricted the strategy of
of the Iranians basically saying you
can't use drones, you can't fight back,
uh you can't cheat, you can't fight
asymmetrically and then in that
iteration in the final iteration the
Pentagon won. Okay, so this shows you
two things. The first thing is that the
Pentagon is not ready to fight a war
asymmetrically. uh it doesn't have the
creativity, it doesn't have the
resilience, it doesn't have the
flexibility. The second thing is the
Pentagon has become this bureaucracy
where it doesn't really want bad news.
It doesn't want to emit its limitations
and so it's going to shape reality in a
way that conforms to its expectations
and and and so that's one piece of
evidence. Another piece of evidence is
operation prosperity guardian where the
hoofies in response to the genocide in
Gaza was um disrupting red sheet red sea
shipping and so the Americans sent this
massive naval armarda to stop the
Houthies right I'm sure you've seen this
video footage of like this massive ama
and it didn't do anything uh they kept
on hitting the hoofies the hoofies hid
in their mount mountains and the hoofies
refused to surrender and the Americans
didn't know what to do because they're
so used to being able to scare the
opponents, to bribe them, to intimidate
them, uh to co-opt them, to assassinate
them. And the Houthies were, you know,
refused to surrender. Um they were not
afraid to die and they could not be uh
blackmailed. And so what happened was
the Americans were forced to retreat.
Now, I saw a YouTube video where these
different admirals got together and
discussed Operation Prosperity Guardian.
And basically um to put it in very
simply what they said was um we lost
against the Houthies. We made a lot of
mistakes but we don't know how to beat
them. But if you ask us to do it again
we'll use the same strategy because we
don't know what else to do.
>> Okay. That's that that's basically the
Pentagon.
>> And so we're seeing this play out right
now in Iran where these strategies don't
really work. uh these past three weeks
have shown uh shotgun all doesn't really
work, but they don't know what else to
do. So, they keep on doing it. And now
what they're doing is they're thinking
about sending marine the Marines in for
an infamous landing because that's just
what you do. Even though every military
analyst you talk to will tell you that
this is a suicide mission. Um um so but
unfortunately once you commit to a war,
the war achieves a momentum and a logic
of its own. And this is what happened in
Vietnam where in 1965 1966 the Americans
basically knew they could not defeat
this insurgency in South Vietnam but
they didn't want to give up because of
credibility or face right they don't
want to look bad in front of the world
and so we're we're seeing a similar
situation where if Americans were to
retreat
well I mean the entire world would just
laugh at Trump I mean the entire world
world would no longer see America as a
empire as invincible. Uh, and the
Pentagon could not really counterance
this possibility. So, what they'll do is
they'll double down. It's it's very much
like going to casino, you know, losing a
million dollars and then you're stuck.
It's a some cost fallacy where, you
know, you either stay stay um and try to
gamble back your money or you go home
and and like have to tell your wife what
happened, right?
>> Can I just stay on this issue of morale
before you change the subject? One more
question about that because it feels
like it doesn't matter that we're all so
upset about the war, but you're saying
it does. But on the other side,
Arab, many Arab countries do have
something to fight for. specifically the
Palestinians, specifically the Iranians.
Living as a Palestinian in Gaza under
constant surveillance where the Israelis
can kill you and rape you at will, lock
you in Gaza, you're waiting decades for
a right of return and living in utter
poverty and misery. To them, the stakes
are utterly existential. So, anyone
aligned with them has nothing to lose.
So they do have moral support whereas
the rest of us don't. Can you explain
how that plays into their because
there's if they lose they're all wiped
out. There's nothing. I mean I just
finished Ramsay Birud's book over the
weekend and the way that the
Palestinians in Gaza have been living
for decades is horrific and those are
stories that are not told to us but it's
very motivating to them.
>> Yeah. Look, I think that the Iranians
have extremely high morale and um the
reason why is they think they are on the
side of truth. You know what what people
forget about the Iranians is that these
are the Persians and the Persians have
ramp up for about 3,000 years. And the
Persians were originally Zorastrians and
Zoroastrians um were the first esque
esqueological people in that they
believe that they are here to serve the
will of God and to bring about a just
world. And so they believed like if you
live a life of truth, if you fight for
what is good, then you make the world a
better place. And you know, and that's
why the Iranians refuse to pre do a
preemptive strike. You know, there are a
lot of people telling Iranians, you know
what, the Americans are going to come
anyway. The Israelis are going to come
anyway. Take the initiative. You know,
set the contours of this war. But the
per the Persian people are like, no, we
have to live the truth. We refuse to
submit to the lie. So if they attack us,
we will fight back. But we will we will
never ever be the aggressor. We will
never ever choose the path of violence.
We choose the path of right. And you
know when when you do that, when you
submit yourself to the will of God, when
you um commit yourself to righteousness,
there's an inner fire in you that allows
you to surmount all obstacles that gives
you faith in the the most darkest times.
And you can see that in Iran where you
know they're being devastated. Um in the
first week they really struck an oil dep
in Tran and so the entire sky was black
but inside there's a light shining in
the Iranian people and and that's what
happens when you fight a war for a good
cause as opposed to a um bad cause.
>> You you brought up David Ike earlier and
you know we're big fans of David Ike
here on this show. He's been been a
guest a number of times. One of the
things that he's been saying is that
this Iranian war, this collapse of Iran,
etc., has been planned for a long time.
I mean, this is many, many decades, as
you pointed out, the the the war games
that they were playing at the Pentagon
many decades ago. But this is all part
of a plan, a broader plan. And his
argument is, of course, that Trump is
just like a a pawn in this cultist's
chessboard,
ushering in this new era of AI and
control, and we will lose more rights. I
mean, I just did a video this weekend
about this very same thing. This idea
that they will take away our control,
they will take away our ability to
transact. AI will have, you know, this
biological connection now to the human
brain. They are issuing in this ushering
in this new era of control just like the
Patriot Act. So we can get all into the
finite details about air power and this
drone struck this particular oil plant
and this but really it's part of a
larger game. Do you see it that way?
>> Yeah, I mean I completely agree with
David Ike's assessment. Um I think this
is the future we're heading towards. Um
my main issue with David Ike is that he
thinks this is all deliberate. This is
all scripted. This is all planned. And
it's true that certain people have
planned this out. The these are
occultists. These are people who have
been studying Cabala um and meditating
on the state of the fear state of the
world for many many decades and they
have foreseen these events turn out. But
to say that this is all scripted um
really doesn't take take in account the
agency of certain individuals. Um so to
say like this will ultimately lead to a
certain um series of events I agree
with. I think this will lead to digital
currency. I think this will lead to u an
AI surveillance uh control grid. I think
this will lead to collapse of the global
economy. I think this will lead to a
reset. I think this will lead to the
greater Israel project. So on where the
world is heading um I agree with David
Ike. But but I will also point out that
according to game theory, we cannot
discount certain players in this game.
So for example, Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin are major players in this
game and their interests are not
actually aligned with the interests of
the global elite. Yes, the global elite
has a certain plan for us and this war
is meant to achieve this plan, but um
Vladimir Putin and Donald Trump may have
other plans as as well. And what we're
seeing is really um the script being
played out, but also a response to this
script. So, I don't think I don't think
things will work out as uh seamlessly as
people predict.
>> Yeah. No, I I I see what you mean and I
think I think you're spot on with that
because there are individual players in
this that have agency and can
manipulate. There is a broader
framework, whatever you want to call it,
this 2030 agenda, more broadly, control
grid, etc., a digital currency. They
want massive control of all of us and
really co 19 of course was the was the
trial run to see how far they could push
us into these lockdowns. Do you believe
that we are heading into a massive
energy lockdown the likes of which we've
never seen before even eclipsing what we
saw with CO 19? You're already seeing
obviously in Southeast Asia you talked
about Thailand. Um in your interview
with Tucker uh Thailand already on uh
fuel restrictions and telling people to
stay home. They've I think declared a
state of emergency. Uh Vietnam and other
countries as well. So do you think we
are heading for a massive lockdown?
I actually think um the real issue that
the elite global global global elite
need to resolve is uh the financial
system. Meaning like over the past 10 20
years they printed too much money and
there are too many individuals who are
millionaires and this is causing a lot
of problems for the global economy. Um
and so what you need to do is basically
destroy a lot of this wealth. And there
are different options that that you can
use to destroy this wealth. A civil war
in America would would do it. A false
flag attack on financial data centers
where uh a lot of wealth is wiped out um
will also work. Uh and then you can
blame this false flag on Iran and
therefore muster public support for a
national draft. So so I think like their
priority is not necessarily to lock the
the the country down, but to try to
destroy as much excess wealth as
possible from the system in order to
better regulate individuals.
>> That's terrifying. I mean, yeah, maybe
not the the lockdown in the COVID sense
of the term, but locking us down
financially. Yes.
>> By wiping out huge stores of value.
That's absolutely terrifying.
>> Yes. Uh I do want to talk about these
dark forces a little bit more because um
the Epstein class is clearly a real
thing. And how much of the Epstein class
do you think is just that they're
satanic perverts doing things for their
own satisfaction? And that it does
promote a war. Is it is it a a chess
piece to move around? I have you as
someone who eats babies. Therefore, you
must give me the war that I wanted. What
do you think of that? Because you talk a
lot about the Epstein class. Uh was it
real in the way that most of us see now
from the public documents. What have we
not seen and how is it operating still?
Because it clearly didn't die with
Epstein. Die with Epstein.
>> Yeah. So, um, the Epstein class, I think
people focus on the wrong thing, which
is they focus on pizza gate, right? They
focus on the idea that Epste was talking
about like beef jerky, uh, pizza and
grape soda. And that's what captivates
the people's imagination. But I think
that's not really the point. Okay. And
what I mean by that is um we think that
you know Jeffrey Epstein was running a
uh blackmail operation um and using
Epstein Island in order to gather
compromising material on powerful
individuals like Bill Clinton and Bill
Gates. I think Epstein Island was just a
weekend getaway. It's just what he did
for fun.
>> You actually look at the Epson files and
you track what he was doing. Well, he
was basically an operative for the
global elite and trying to manufacture
geopolitical events in a certain way
that most benefit benefited um the
global elite. Right? So, um he was
involved in the great financial crisis
of 2008. he was probably involved in 911
even though we don't have the emails um
that confirm this but um a lot of if you
just connect the dots it it suggest that
he was in in a certain way involved in
911 you know um he was a neighbor to
Howard Lugnik in um in Manhattan right
so and uh they were neighbors and their
numbers were 9 and 11 so is this all
coincidence you know I I mean like I I
don't know but um so what I will say is
this if you just look at u the Epian
files and you try to reconstruct how he
was making his money and what his real
job was. Well, he was mainly engaged in
arms trafficking, money laundering um
and um and geop geopolitical
manipulation and that and so it was
basically an operative and the money was
just something that he did um I mean it
it was not a concern. I mean think about
this where um Bill Gates and Reed
Hoffman these are billionaires when they
were asked why do you associate with
Epstein and their response was well we
wanted money from him right so these are
billionaires trying to beg Epstein for
money so so something's wrong with our
current conception of the world and so
what I will say is there is a
transnational elite that is above the
nation state that um is able to
manipulate the nation state and this
transnational elite is able to man
manipulate geopolitical events in a
certain way that maximizes their
benefit. Okay. And we can speculate as
to who these who this transnational
elite um are. But I will say that that
they are an alliance between three
forces. Okay. These three forces are
transational capital, uh, city of
London, Wall Street, uh, secret
societies, Jesuits, um, um, Shabbat
Lubovich, um, Sabatine Francis,
Freemasons, Rosian, and then you have
these elite families called the 13
families that apparently control the
world. Okay, so I would say Epstein was
one of these people from an elite
family. And if you look at his emails,
what he will say is there were three
major Jewish families in Europe. They
were the Rothschilds, the Epstein, and
the Gutmans. And he said, he told Peter
Theo, I represent the Rothschilds. And
what he's really saying is, I represent
a collection of transnational capital
that is able to influence geopolitical
events. So I think that is what what the
Epstein class is. The Epstein class are
parasites on the nation state and they
manipulate geopolitical events in a
certain way that most benefits them. you
know, Joe Kent uh last week uh I think
it was last week now um time is flying
so quickly uh resigned from the Trump
administration um basically trying to
prevent this war in Iran. He says that
everybody all of the intelligence
agencies have confirmed that Iran was
did not have nuclear ambitions. They
were not building nuclear weapons.
President Trump um just on Monday comes
out and says, you know, the whole reason
we're having these negotiations, no more
wars and we will not allow Iran to get
those nuclear weapons. So there seems to
be this massive disconnect. Joe Kent
posted this and I just want to read it
to you. He said, "Step one in
deescalation must be restraining the
Israelis. Otherwise, all efforts to
negotiate will follow this pattern."
Well, president of the United States
will announce a deescalation and then
Israel launches some major attack on oil
infrastructure or desalinization plants.
And that's what we've seen now
repeatedly in these past few weeks is
that the United States says one thing
and then the Israelis like go around
quickly and launch some sort of attack
on Iranian infrastructure. Like you
mentioned the oil and the black cloud
hanging over Tyrron. So do you agree
with Joe Kent that the really the only
way to deescalate is to rein in the
Israelis?
>> I completely agree with with this
assessment. So in the early days of the
war uh on the first day uh a drone
struck the Saudi Arab facility in Saudi
Arabia and we assumed at first that was
Iranians but later it was reported that
actually this drone was coming in from
Lebanon. So the Iranians launch a drone
from uh Lebanon, right? So people
speculate that this was an Israeli false
flag to force Saudi Arabia into the war
as quickly as possible. Her Carlson
himself reported that he was told by
confidential sources that the Qataris
had arrested two MSAD agents who they
suspected of sabotaging um of of doing a
sabotage operation in in Qatar. Later
the Qataris denied this, but you know
this fits very much the um Mossad MO. Uh
recently there was a long range missile
strike on the Diego Garcia and at first
people were bewilder because we just
assumed this was beyond the uh range of
Iran's ballistic missiles but now it's
being reported that actually these
missiles uh were fired from an Israeli
submarine. So it is in the best interest
according to game theory for Israel to
drag this war out as much as possible
and drag in as many players as possible.
Ideally, Israel also wants to drag drag
in Saudi Arabia, UAE, Turkey, uh, and
Pakistan as well because from their
perspective, this war is the best
opportunity they have to achieve the
greater Israel project. If they destroy
the GCC, if they destroy Iran, then they
are the only regional power left
standing and and that is their um
ambition.
But also, sorry,
>> no, go ahead. I know. Yeah, but but but
I will also add some nuance uh to this
where the Iranians do not actually want
this war to end as well because for the
past few decades they've been under
tremendous uh sanctions and they want to
they want sanctions relief. Um and they
recognize that if they are to rebuild
and modernize and for f forever protect
themselves, they need to accomplish
certain things. The first thing they
need to do is is establish control over
the street of Kumus. uh and that would
be the main economic lifeline where they
can charge a 10% toll on any um uh
passage through the street of Humus. So
that's number one. Number two is they
need to eliminate the uh American
military presence in the GCC. Uh so they
need to America out of the Middle East.
The third thing they they need to do is
uh establish credibility. Meaning they
need to do enough damage to Israel so
that Israel will force the will force uh
will be forced to be respectful towards
Iran and then Israel and Iran can come
to a peace treaty once the United States
leaves. So that that's really the
long-term ambition of Iran as well.
>> Is that doable that Israel will ever
submit to the greater good of other
countries?
Right. So if you look at the greater
Israel project, it's very clear that it
extends from the Nile to the Euphrates.
It does not include Persia. Israel is
not actually interested in Persia. So
according to game theory, what Israel
wants to do is knock out both the GCC
and and and um the United States. So
people don't don't really understand
this where people think that Israel's
main objective is knock out Iran. No,
actually, uh, Israel sees America as a
main threat. There there's a video, a
viral video of of Nanyahu, and a
journalist asked him, "What book are you
reading right now, uh, Mr. Nanyahu?" And
Na responds, "I'm reading a book called
Rome versus the Jews by Barry Strauss."
And this and the book is about these
three wars fought between the Romans and
the Jews um in the first century. And
these were like brutal wars that wiped
out uh most of the Jewish population in
Europe at that time. And so the
journalist then asked Nanyahu, why are
you reading this book? And Na's response
was was, "Well, it didn't work out great
for us the first time." Okay, so this is
how the Israelis think. They see they
they understand like their main
competitor in the Middle East is
actually not Iran, but actually United
States. So this war is meant to actually
destroy the American military presence
in the Middle East. sit on that for I
mean yeah just
>> yeah it it's very much like Game of
Thrones I keep mentioning there's this
little finger character who is
befriending these leaders and then
leading them and advising them into
their own self-destruction if you know
Game of Thrones that would make sense
and so I guess my question is and it's
not you know the people of Israel it's
the leaders of Israel who want this
these are in my estimation, the bad
guys.
Is there any scenario in your game
theory where the bad guys are punished
and stop it? I know that's simplistic,
but it's like what I pray for.
>> Look, there's a lot of agency. Um, and
Donald Trump could have a come to Jesus
moment and he strikes a deal with the
Iranians and he restricts the Israelis,
right? So Donald Trump says, "For the
greater good, I'm going to strike a deal
with the GCC and Iran, and we're going
to limit Israel." Now, Israel has
nuclear weapons, so you can't attack
Israel. But what the United States can
do is we're going to pass laws that say
you cannot be a dual citizen and sit in
the US Congress. Um, you cannot be a
dual citizen and work in the National
Security Apparatus of America. Um, and
we're not we're not going to sell
weapons to Israel, and we're not we're
not going to finance um um the military
activities of of Israel. I mean, the
reality is the Israelis have free
healthcare, and a lot of this being
financed by Americans who do not have
free healthcare, by the way.
>> Yeah, we know this.
>> Yeah. [laughter] Yeah. Exactly. And
they're mil and they have a space
program. Like, why are we propping up a
country that has a space program? It's
incredibly frustrating because federal
workers are not being paid at the
airports. We, you know, just traveled
this weekend and we walk through and
it's heartbreaking to watch these people
go without paychecks and know that we're
spending all this money to bomb Iran.
It's it's really hard to take.
>> So, Professor, um, we're going to take a
quick break and we're going to come
back. We want to ask you about your next
big prediction and also about something
you said uh last week, which is that
this war powers we could be entering
into with President Trump could even
lead to a potential Trump third term. Uh
we'll talk about all of that in a
moment. But first, well, don't you hate
when people say, "I told you so." Yeah,
that's me actually because I I did tell
you. Sorry, but I told you that gold and
silver were going to reap the benefits
of excessive money printing. The Fed
just printing money like crazy.
overvalued markets, global unrest. It's
here. It's happened. Gold and silver
have both soared to all-time highs.
[music]
So, I hope you called our friends at
Lear Capital and you bought some. If you
didn't, trust me, it's not too late.
Experts are predicting even higher
prices ahead. And they get it. They know
what's coming. Isn't it time, folks? Get
yourself some gold and silver today.
Call the best in the [music] business. I
personally use them. So does Natalie. We
both do. And our kids do as well in
their IAS. Lear Capital, it's a free
phone call.
>> [music]
>> There's no obligation to purchase, just
education, information on protecting and
growing your wealth with gold and
silver. I'm sure there are many of you
that have called and haven't purchased
yet for whatever reason. Don't make the
same mistake twice. Now is the time to
get some gold shipped directly to you or
shift some dollars in your retirement
accounts over to physical gold and
silver. It's easy to do. Natalie and I
have done it for both and I've been
extremely satisfied with [music] Lear's
knowledge, their service, their prices.
I urge you to call today and learn more.
or call them 18006133557
or go to leerred redacted.com and you
can receive up to $20,000 in free bonus
medals with a qualified purchase. All
right, we're back with Professor Jiang
and uh to talk more about his
predictions here and as well as possibly
a Trump third term. Professor, I I
before we get into the Trump third term
piece of this, as you're gaming out this
war now and things have changed, I'm
sure since this the the first three and
a half weeks of this thing, where are
you seeing your predictions pointing o
over the next month, maybe year or so?
Um, are there any predictions that you'd
want to reveal here on our show?
Yeah. So, um I will say that I think
this war is heading in the direction of
another Vietnam. Meaning that 1965,
um the Americans sent in about 3,000
Marines in a in an expeditionary unit to
control Dagnan air air base. And this
was a limited operation with a limited
military objective. And then like four
or five years later, you have half a
million troops in Vietnam. Uh and so we
can see a similar situation play out in
Iran where uh the Americans deploy the
Marines in a limited operation possibly
to uh secure a coastline uh possibly to
uh take Car Island. We don't know yet.
Um but then um this will lead to
escalation because of some cost fallacy
and mission creep where the the military
set up so that it wants to win a war and
once it gets in a fight it's not going
to stop until it wins the war. Uh and
that's what and that's what happened in
Vietnam. Um so once these troops are
sent no matter what happens uh whether
or not they are successful in the first
strike or not successful the Pentagon
wants uh to finish the job basically and
there'll be a lot of pressure from the
military on Donald Trump to institute a
national draft um and and so I think he
will have no choice in the matter but
institute a national draft uh in which
case you will have riots throughout
America and they have a plan for that
right they want to deploy the national
guard across across all major American
cities by um as early as April.
And once that is in place, once you have
the National Guard is in place, then um
Trump can declare the Emergency Powers
Act, right? And then he will get his
third term uh and as well as bypass the
midterm elections in November.
>> So a third term without an election,
sort of like Zalinsky basically.
>> Well, right. I mean, he already has a
war without congressional declaration.
And so again, I come back to we have
rules and orders and all of them are
just being steamrolled right now that it
doesn't it and and you can hear my
despair in the fact that it feels like
you're not supposed to attack civilian
living infrastructure. Oh, we did that.
You're not supposed to attack civilians.
Yes, we did that. You're not supposed to
level a whole society in Gaza. Yeah, we
did that, too. You're not supposed to
have a war without congressional
approval. You're not I I don't know what
to do here. Right. The fact that the
rules don't matter and yet you can still
see what's being played out in in a game
when there's no rules.
>> Right. So I think it's very worrying
that this war was started started in a
way uh that was not the way the war
started in 2003. So in 2003
the Bush administration spent months um
rallying public support. They won
congressional approval. They spoke
before the United Nations and prov and
provided um suspicious specious evidence
of weapons of mass destruction but they
provided evidence nonetheless. Okay. So
so the American government in 2003 made
tremendous efforts to win over the
American public to seek congressional
approval and to also win public opinion.
Okay. To speak before the United
Nations. None of this is true. Um today
the the Trump administration went in and
even today they have not provided
actually a reason why they made the
first strike. Trump has said that well
it was because it was misled by his
adviser Steve Wov Jared Kushner Peter
Hassv and then Marco Rubio has said that
well it's because the Israelis would
attack first and then the Iranians were
going to respond by attacking us and so
we have to preempt the Israelis.
Wow.
>> I mean, you know, I I normally wouldn't
want to point out the Economist magazine
professor. I'm not a fan of that liberal
rag normally, but um at the airport,
just reading the front cover, I think
the the headline, the front cover of the
Economist magazine this past week is a
war with no plan. And I think you just
hit the nail on the head. I mean, what
is the plan here? Is there a plan? Do
you see that there is an endgame?
Because people are asking, what's the
goal here? Well, we're nuclear, you
know, no more nuclear weapons. Well,
they never had nuclear weapons. They
weren't building nuclear weapons. It's
to help the Iranian people. So, you help
the Iranian people by killing their
children and bombing their oil and
desalinization infrastructure. Like,
none of it makes sense. Do you see any
of it making sense?
>> But let me just point out having that
within weeks of the start of the war is
something different. We we had to wait
years in the Iraq war to get this kind
of narrative. we can at least have it
from strike one. So there's my I've been
so pessimistic this whole interview. So
I wanted to point out that I can see
silver linings.
>> Look, I mean, if you just look at uh
America's history in the Middle East for
the past 20 years, um what they did in
Iraq, what they did in Libya and Syria,
I think there is a plan. The plan is to
bulcanize Iran into ethnic archives and
destroy Iran's uh limited water
infrastructure. basically destroy the
reservoirs uh the power plants and have
these um different ethnic groups fight
over water for the next few few decades.
It's really to destroy Persia as a
civilization and that's exactly what
they did in Iraq. So remember in 2003
the war was one won one won very quickly
and then uh Paul Bremer was appointed to
oversee the transition and the second
act okay the second thing he did was
something called the debuffation act
which said that if you were a member of
the Baptist party you were not allowed
to work in government. You were not
allowed to work in the military. You
were not allowed to work in in the
police. The problem with that is that
everyone who worked in government,
everyone who worked in the military,
everyone who worked in the police was a
member of the Baptist party. And so with
that one order, it destroyed uh the
nation state of Iraq. It destroyed the
government of Iraq and and its ability
to deliver basic services to uh the
Iraqi people and what and this led to
massive sectarian violence um that's
still raging today in in Iraq. So, I
think that's the that's the end goal in
Iran to do what to do in Iran what they
did in Iraq and Libya and Syria, but
they can't come out and say this because
the entire world would be disgusted uh
with with this plan. [snorts]
>> I guess we'll get you out of here on
this, Professor. We haven't really
talked about the media propaganda piece
of all of this, which is really ramped
into overdrive. Have you heard over the
past few days the same publications that
were telling us in the Ukraine war that
Russia had run out of ballistic missiles
is the same media that's now telling us
that Iran has run out of ballistic
missiles and they are being hindered and
they're being shattered and you know
this will wrap up very very soon. How do
you when you when you analyze the media
propaganda arm of all of this? How do
you see it unfolding?
>> Right. So, I think you're exactly
correct in like the media um um will
just be as propagistic in this war
against Iran as it was against Ukraine.
Um, so the problem with this though is
unfortunately Washington DC has become
an insular bubble and so if you are
negative, if you voice any disscent, if
you're critical like Joe Kent, well,
you're pushed out of the bubble very
quickly. And so basically, everyone in
Washington DC is drinking their own
Kool-Aid, you know, getting high on on
their own supply. This is very
problematic because it will lead to bad
decision decision making and this is
what we saw in Ukraine where it was I
mean like it was suicidal for Ukraine to
launch counter offensive against a
heavily fortified Russian position and
by launching three counter offensive
that led to to that led nowhere that
accomplished no military objectives they
the Ukrainians lost over about a million
uh men of fighting age and but
unfortunately because the deep state
because uh Washington DC is able to
control the nar the media narrative
people aren't aware of this and so this
war in Ukraine is dragging on for no
particular reason uh even though it's
led to the destruction of Ukraine as a
nation state and even though this war is
not winnable and we can see a similar
situation in um um Iran where the war is
being lost where it's clear that the
Iranians refuse to give up and they
clear escalation control. But Donald
Trump is watching Fox News and he's
watching, you know, NSB, NBC and CNN and
CBS News and they have to tell him
exactly what he wants to hear, which is
this war is going great. The Iranian
people love you. The Iranian people want
democratic change and one more day and
we've got this. The Iranians are so
close to collapse and we just stick on
we just f on for one more week. We've
got this and then like five years later
we're still at the stupid war.
Well, professor, thank you for like
staying awake for us. Um, and uh and
joining us on this show. I know the time
zones are really really
>> Sorry. Um um before we end, I I just
want to give give a quick shout out to
Tucker Carlson, okay? Because people
don't remember this, but we could have
been in the situation in January 2020
because that's when Trump uh ordered the
assassination of General Kasam Salammani
in Baghdad. And this was clearly an act
of war in and it seemed as though the
Americans were going to follow us up
with air strikes against Iran. So we
should have been in a situation in
January. But what happened was Ter
Carlson on Fox News using his huge
platform every day. He explained why
this war would be disaster for America.
I I think he even flew down to Mara Lago
to talk to Trump personally. Okay. But
Ter Carlson saved us from nuclear war in
January 2020 and for that he was fired
from Fox News and people don't don't
remember what a what a heroic act that
was because he's the only broadcaster in
a major platform that came out um to
speak out against the war
>> great personal risk. Yes, he continues
to do that at great personal risk. So
yes.
>> Yeah. And then speaking out against the
Ukraine war and the the United States
involvement in that, you know, you know,
that's why, yes, that and that's why he
got fired from Fox News. Um, clearly
Professor um Yeah, 100%. One of the few
voices on national television who was
calling out these neocons and this
boondoggle that would have been a
disaster for the United States. So,
thank you for that. Uh, Professor, thank
you so much for the wacky time zones and
and burning the midnight oil um to to be
up with us. We really really appreciate
it. Thank you for your incredible work.
We want to drive everyone to your
Substack and to your YouTube channel.
Um, it's remarkable. So, thank you so
much, professor. We'd love to have you
back. Really appreciate it.
>> Yeah. No, I I love talking to you guys.
Yeah. I mean, uh I would love to come
back.
>> We've been looking forward to it. So,
yeah. Open invitation.
>> Thanks, professor. Yeah. Anytime. You're
welcome. So, thank you so much. really
appreciate it.